hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video an und titel eingeblendet warum
studiere ich ist ein thema über das ich
heute reden wollte und da gestern am
dienstag eigentlich immer minecraft
kommt habe ich mir gedacht hat heute
einfach minecraft hoch und nähmen das
ein bisschen als gameplay unterlage
sondern grundlage heißt glaube ich eher
einfach damit ich nicht so vor der cam
sitze einfach sondern damit wir noch ein
bisschen was zu gucken habt also würde
ich sagen dass wir uns jetzt direkt an
katyn minecraft stürzen
wir befinden uns hier in der welt das
letzte mal minecraft haben glaube ich
vor einer woche hier und ist immer noch
die spinne weil in der letzten folge
hatten wir ja hier diese falle so ein
bisschen aufgebaut also hier vorne ist
ja die der spieler drin
wir haben jetzt noch keine falle so
richtig aber ich wollte hier eigentlich
die felder hin machen deswegen überlege
ich gerade hier zum zweiten boden rein
zu bauen
ich glaub das mache ich auch jetzt
können natürliche oder können weiß ich
gar nicht so genau
also ihr seht schon im titel
eingeblendet ich habe hier auch schon
die letzte folge offen also da wurden
wir mit schreibe ich ein kommentar ist
natürlich verwerfen
ich habe die letzte folge offen wir
wurden mega viele kommentare geschrieben
also ich habe hier an der anzahl 11.000
kommentare mit themen und da wurde alles
geschrieben von wegen
luca du kritisierst du auf deinem haus
ist doch eigentlich gar nicht so kacke
ausliegt wirklich nur daran dass du die
settings ein bisschen schlecht
eingestellt hat man die ganze welt sieht
bei mir beschissen aus ihr wird ein
geiles texture pack hier drin oder so
und da kam auch sachen an macht auch mal
master builders mit anderen youtube an
und sogar kam wirklich viele viele
kommentare an
auch sehr viele nette kommentare und
dafür wollte ich mich einfach mal
bedanken
dass ihr da rücksicht nehmen das lohnt
sich nicht das für ein ding darin haben
sich damit einen tag ein bisschen
rücksicht nehmen dass ich echt nicht der
beste spieler in einem spiel bin aber
also was soll ich denn jetzt sagen ja
was auch geschrieben wurde wo ich mir
dann direkt gedacht okay darüber könnte
ich eigentlich echt mal reden war wie
warum ich eigentlich studieren weil ich
das ja wirklich teilweise in videos
sagen so von wegen jahr leute auch wenn
youtube nicht mehr doch egal ich habe
ich wenig vorkommt wie hoch ihr wissen
wenn ihr eine hochschul seiner seite
weiß ich gar nicht oder sind schon
ordentlich viel was ich eigentlich
gerade vor habe war ich hier ja diese
farmen reinpacken moment ich muss ich
mir ganz gut orientieren bevor ich mit
dem thema anfang nicht weiß
das regt mich selber immer wenn ich mal
gaming videoshow es regt mich auch immer
auf dass die sich da immer so elendig
lange zeit lassen ist überhaupt man mit
irgendeinem thema anfangen aber ich
möchte mich einfach dem thema widmen und
vorher dass hier alles fertig geklatscht
haben also was ich hier auf jeden fall
brauche sind komplett stones weil ich
das ja alles einheitlich haben möchte
als ich hier so ein bisschen durch die
erzielen wirklich gerade das erste mal
so einen fortschritt in diesem let's
play würde ich sagen
also so weit so das ganze wirklich circa
gehen das heißt diese band ii muss auf
jeden fall auch noch weg und dass
darüber auch noch
ich hatte ja schon mal so ein bisschen
anfang zu quatschen um das es mir geht
und warum ich das thema anschneiden
viele leute oder ich sage es oft wie ist
es ich studiere und immer wenn ich mit
gegen den interviews führen und ich ihr
wisst wahrscheinlich alle ich füge sehr
selten interviews und wenn schon
wirklich nur nicht ob das jetzt hab ich
mit dem spiegel geführt und ich jetzt
blöd kommen hier hoch
überlegt schon dass ich mir dass man so
kurz abgrenze dass ich weiß okay hier
unter den kombis das ist die falle
ich meine ihr werdet jetzt
wahrscheinlich die ganze zeit in dem
video diese blöden spinnen irgendwie
hören aber müsse halt mit lebende halt
verschissen ist so ein scheiß bonner
hier also wenn ich in interviews wenn
ich interviews gebe es halt so eine
frage die auch thema gestellt wird jo du
wirkst gestalt wie kommst du denn da
hoch die frage würden sie nicht gestellt
sondern ich werde immer gefragt ja du
studierst du auch nebenbei möglichstes
als nein hut und so was alles und die
rede da eigentlich nie drüber sondern
nur in meinen interviews und sagt dann
halt so ja schon irgendwie hin seht ihr
geld noch schaffe das auch alles
irgendwie aber so warum ich wirklich
studieren habe ich eigentlich noch nie
wirklich beantwortet immer nur so teils
und das sollte in diesem video machen
und ihr seht wahrscheinlich schon okay
wir sind schon mal minute 4 in diesem
video und etwa widerspruch einschätzen
lokal mach mal nicht dass es nicht mehr
so lange mir ich denke das video wird
wieder also auf die 20 minuten zu geben
war das ist minecraft
das ist einfach ein video was ich mit
einer woche erlauben wo ich wirklich
raushauen was männer angeht raushauen
dass den städten geht also negativen
sinne dass ich einfach nicht schneider
ja deswegen das ist quasi so die idee
von diesem minecraft projekt und ich
meine wenn ihr hier seid und jetzt im
westen erwartet ihr halt gerne ein
anderes video von mir anschauen die sind
natürlich auch nicht
anderes so jetzt hätte ich mir gar nicht
die hilfe festgelegt wo der spaß aufhört
aber ich glaube das war hier oder ja
genau da hier sondern dieser stelle so
kann ich diese sachen jetzt auch er
kommt also warum studieren
das ist kann ich euch eigentlich nicht
beantworten es war so dass ich
irgendwann nach dem abi natürlich auch
youtube gemacht habe aber da habe ich
mit youtube vielleicht im monat
wie meinen jeder kann jeder zweite
youtuber erzählt ja auch wie viel er
verdient auf fakten ich dachte ich
müsste es zu bauen oder so ok crazy
school keiner gekommen
jeder zweite youtube erzählt die auf den
fehler verdient ich bin jetzt eigentlich
nicht so einer der damit prahlt und sagt
ich mache jetzt hier so und so viele
millionen klicks und die und die
placement oder so ich war halt ist
eigentlich ganz gern für mich also ich
denke jeder weiß dass youtuber nicht
gerade schlecht verdienen allerdings war
es halt für mich nach dem abi nicht der
fall dass ich gesagt habe youtube ist
das ding was ich unbedingt machen will
in meinem leben und das heißt jetzt
nicht dass ich kein bock habe mehr auf
youtube sondern ganz im gegenteil ich
hatte mega bock auf youtube aber für
mich war es einfach so die sache
youtuber die youtube videos machen
hauptberuflich gutes deutsch sind
komplett dorf aber meiner ansicht nach
ist es einfach ein bisschen unklug
das zu machen also jeder wird sich da
wahrscheinlich irgendwas bei denken und
ich meinen viele verdienen ja auch geld
das sie auch wenn sie jetzt plötzlich
nichts mehr verdienen würden direkt sag
ich mal noch zehn jahre locker damit
leben könnten mit dem bisher verdienten
der sentry portal kaktus ich weiß nicht
und stehe will ich jetzt also man
bestellt das video
dass sie wirklich locker da lange vom
noch mit von links
aber ich bin halt mehr der mensch im
sitzen quasi genau von den punkt zu
bringen warum ich studiere irgendwann
wenn ich keinen bock mehr auf youtube
habe allerdings aufgrund meiner
entscheidung früher nicht selbstständig
mit youtube zu machen nur mit youtube
geld zu verdienen und nicht nebenbei zu
machen bin ich gezwungen videos zu
machen nur um über die runden zu kommen
um mein geld zu verdienen weil ich ein
nebenbei nichts in der tasche habe
versteht ihr was ich meine
ich kenne youtuber die schule
abgebrochen haben nicht mal wie und
machen nur youtube
da denke ich mir nur leute youtube ist
sonst schnelllebiges geschäft
so ich nenne es mal wirklich geschäfts
geschäft auf seiner business ebene im
moment muss man da hinten bisschen brot
so dass ich so ein bisschen hier nur
blabla ich habe habe ich mache mir die
farben da hinten um besser bauherrschaft
du bist auf firmen statt
ich mache mir da hinten die fahren damit
ich nicht immer den ganzen weg ball
drüber laufen musste meiner kleinen
scheiß vater hin
ich weiß nicht wo ich den geblieben war
aber überhaupt nichts gegen die youtuber
oder was dabei gedacht haben aber viel
spiel überhaupt mir so ein typ ich
könnte niemals sagen okay ich scheiß auf
meine zukunft und habe keine absicherung
erst hört sich cool an
also muss ich wirklich zugeben und wegen
ja auch ich mache mich selbstständig mit
youtube macht da mein ding wird bestimmt
alles klappen und ich reise um die welt
und ist supertoll wie time of my life
aber man muss halt wirklich ich will ja
nicht der spielverderber sein ihr wisst
ich bin für alles offen ich habe ich oft
genug storys erzähl ich einfach mit
freunden einfach gedacht habe ja okay
lass irgendwohin fliegen wir sind
irgendwo hin geflogen und ich war alba
team moral endlich wirklich viel in
meinem leben ich bin jetzt kein kein
langweiler der sagt jo sparer geld und
macht nichts oder so dann wäre ich der
falsche tür wird werde bei mir wirklich
eine falsche adresse
aber leute ihr müsst ein bisschen auf
eure finanzen gucken dass das irgendwie
klar geht dass sie irgendwie über die
runden kommt und das ist quasi der
hauptgrund warum ich frag mich immer
wieder warum kein sound kommt wenn ich
ein brötchen es hier aber es ist halt
einfach in der version nicht möglich
gewesen dass man da was hört also der
grund warum ich studiere war wirklich
dass wenn irgend wann ich mein stellt
euch mal vor ich mache ich mache ja
youtube und ich würde jetzt nicht
studieren dann hätte ich wahrscheinlich
nicht gerade zwei millionen abonnenten
erreicht sondern drei millionen
abonnenten erreicht wenn man sich
einfach viel mehr mit der materie
auseinander setzen kann und ich bin kein
typ wie max brandstifter ich will ich
überhaupt nicht fertig machen oder
dessen oder so ist max ist einer meiner
besten freunde aller zeiten und ich mag
den unglaublich gerne und endete das
auch nicht übel wenn ich das sage aber
max ist hat er faul und das sagte er
selber auch in seinen videos er hat so
oft ideen aber dann sind leute einfach
nicht da und max da nicht so ein typ der
dann weiter denkt dann denkt okay das
ist jetzt hat keiner damit ihm das
aufnehmen kann mache ich halt
keine ahnung ein anderes video sondern
macht dann okay dann fahre ich einfach
morgen zu einem kumpel nehmen das dann
da bei ihm auf ich bin halt eher so
einer wenn ich wirklich lust ich habe
einen ganzen tag zeit um youtube zu
machen
dann würde ich mich morgens um 8 uhr an
meinem pc setzen übels durch rasseln und
irgendwie 23 videos am tag raus hauen
megatrucks geschnitten wird mir gedanken
machen mit denen mit den trends und wie
ich das irgendwie aufbauen kann
endlich bist du tot alter wird mir
gedanken machen sich das aufbauen kann
das video so dass es irgendwie cool
passt und von der zeit her passt und
faxt hat sich an als ob die
herunterspringen und alles mögliche also
das tut mir echt leid die ganze zeit die
spinnen hören müsse aber so wäre es halt
bei mir wenn ich youtube hauptberuflich
machen würde allerdings stellt euch mal
vor luca war beruflich youtube 23 jahre
ist er noch gewollt sage ich mal dann
erlaube ich mir skandal oder das ist
natürlich schlimmste sache dass ich
medienskandal sorry ich gerade so
gelaufen bin ich hab das voll oft so
dass ich mir denkt okay das ist schäbig
sicheren her zu handeln ich weiß warum
ich bin krank im kopf weil ich jetzt
noch mal sagen also meine mutter
schreibt mir gerade auf meine oma mir
zum namenstag gratuliert hat weil es ist
gerade ich nehme es wieder um 18.10
aufbau luca der name lukas namenstag
toll schreibt mir alle alles gute die
kommentare supercool samstag mit aber
mit meinen omas und opas turin wieder
halt immer und dich beide gerade
angerufen während der aufnahme deswegen
soria myopie weltweit ihr das seht de
nicht weil ihr nicht mit klassik das
machen um beim thema zu bleiben
ich bin nicht dumm
also ja ich stelle euch freuen was der
23 jahre youtuber bis 3 millionen
abonnenten aber irgendwie glaube ich mit
linken skandal und keiner guckt nicht
mehr oder irgendwie konnte nicht mehr
gewollt oder irgendwie möglich die leute
nicht mehr blabla ich mache auf jeden
fall keine klicks mehr kein geld mehr
mit nicht mehr gewollt von marken keiner
macht mit mm irgendwas könnte ich
vielleicht noch ein zwei jahre mit
meinen einnahmen irgendwie leben oder
vielleicht werde ich dann auch im buch
bergen welche die drittklassigen tv
shows oder so aber dann war es das
und dann bin ich unten durch und dann
hab ich nicht
und der ist das ist der grund warum ich
studiere weil dann müsste ich youtube
machen weil es mein job ist weil ich
geld verdienen muss und das wäre die
einzige motivation dann noch oder sagen
wir nicht mal dass ich unten durchgehend
bei den leuten um mich keiner mehr
gucken will aber einfach ganz simpel
genommen ich hab keinen bock auf dem
video mal an dem tag natürlich kann man
sagen okay youtuber die jetzt in einer
größenordnung sage ich mal so ein
bisschen arrogant jetzt hier gesagt
die können sich das mal erlauben meinen
tag nichts hochzuladen das nehmen die
leute einen nicht krumm
und man kann auch locker noch drei vier
wochen können wir machen dann wird
trotzdem mit den einnahmen auskommen
aber man fühlt sich dann trotzdem
gezwungen videos zu machen weil man
denkt okay es ist mein job ich muss ja
irgendwie geld verdienen und bei mir ist
es einfach so wenn ich kein video macher
denken ein scheiß egal
youtube ist nicht mein job meine einzige
sache die wirklich pflicht ist in meinem
leben ist das studium dass ich da
erscheine dass sich die klausuren
schreiben und das sich irgendwie am ende
mein bett statt kriege und ihr seht
schon ich quatsch dass demenz nicht an
wirklich dass ich jetzt gerade
angefangen habe zu studieren sondern ich
bin wirklich ich schreibe in vier
monaten meine bachelorarbeit also ich
studiere schon mehr zwei jahre zwei
jahre und zwei monate studiere ich schon
und ich studiere noch zehn monate also
wie gesagt in vier monaten fangen am
ende match habe zu schreiben
da schreibe ich dann quasi ein halbes
jahr dran und dann gebe ich die abnahmen
wir nicht fertig mit studieren
deswegen ich wollte das thema extra
nicht ansprechen von wegen als ich
direkt angefangen habe weil dann konnte
doch überhaupt nicht beurteilen mein
studium aber derzeit ist es halt gerade
so dass ich es beurteilen kann und
können einfach froh dass ich es gemacht
habe weil wie gesagt noch mal der grund
ich möchte nicht irgendwann ok gehört
der per gehofft
ganz klar ich möchte nicht irgendwann
hier sitzen und dann habe ich nicht in
der tasche und fragen was habe ich
erreicht in meinem leben wo ich habe ein
paar youtube abonnenten muss man das
irgendwas besonderes können nein
so möchte ich einfach nicht am ende
nicht selbst angucken und ich bin auch
kein mensch der sagt ich kann mit
youtube meinen kompletten tag füllen
also ich meine klar jetzt so youtuber
wien gibt es da den der macht das alles
hauptberuflich ich weiß nicht ich weiß
dass lena das ist einfach nur youtube
macht eigentlich relativ viele piloten
eigentlich gibt ich glaube es machen 90
prozent der youtuber man mit die
hauptprobe youtube und das kann ich
nachvollziehen
jedem sein eigenes ding jeder witz ich
denke was wir denken aber ich kann den
ganzen tag voll mit youtube will
natürlich sagt man ja die anderen machen
krassere videos leute ich kann
einschätzen weil ich ja selber jeden tag
schneide
wie viel die leute schneiden an videos
und wenn ich da wirklich so ein ps
freaks sehe das jetzt irgendwie die
letzten acht tage oder so nichts
hochgeladen um av beruflich youtube das
ist für mich kein leben ich brauch
irgendwas im leben das ist wirklich
überhaupt nichts gegen leute ich kenne
marcel persönlich ist für mich ein
direkter dutt ich kenne den persönlich
ich kenn gallery weekend fast jeden
eigentlich persönlich ist es überhaupt
nichts persönliches gegen die youtuber
wie oft habe ich gerade eigentlich
persönlich gesagt aber es ist ich selber
für mich ist es komplett nicht
nachvollziehbar wie man sein ganzes
leben nur mit youtube füllen kann
natürlich könnte ich ich könnte so viele
deals annehmen es gab so viele projekte
die oder leuten marken nämlich gefragter
marken die in den top ten der meist
teuer der teuersten marken sind wo ich
projekt einfach abgelehnt habe apple war
dabei zwar unter anderem wo ich sachen
einfach abgelehnt habe weil ich ja
ich weiß nicht wie ich das sagen kann
aber ich hätte anrufen rate ich gehe mal
dran
ja ich nehme platten video auf ich nehme
video auf das geht bei dir da kann ich
dich zurückrufen
ich bin da wirklich in der aufnahme ist
ja ich mache dann wirklich reiniger
schoss kollege von mir mit gestern schon
angerufen meine reha begeben weil ich
halt uni hatte ich werd ich mich habe
ich mich gefühlt bitte schön wenn du
siehst du mir leid ich weiß nicht wo ich
stehen geblieben war
aber ich könnte mein leben
wahrscheinlich auch komplett mit youtube
höhen aber ich bin wirklich einfach uns
auf dem ende zu bringen
ich studiere weil ich keinen bock hat
das youtube mein haupt dinge sondern
youtube soll für mich ein hobby bleiben
dass sich auch sagen kann irgendwann ja
auch mir macht youtube keinen spaß mehr
ich halt auch im monat dass ich mir das
erlauben kann dass ich nicht darauf
angewiesen den videos machen aufgrund
der einnahmen et cetera ich finde es hat
sich schon echt cool entwickelt
eigentlich sogar oder also ich weiß dass
die muss ich noch ein bisschen zu
kleistern man alles mögliche aber so vom
denken ja wisst ihr glaube ich muss
ihnen geht und hier soll dann halt eine
riesige fan rhein und in der farbe hier
und es dann halt der mops bonner weiß
ich und da soll dann halt so eine falle
unten rein oder so vielleicht mal jemand
live stream
aber so vom ding her quasi ich will dass
youtube vom hobby für mich bleibt und
für mich kann ein kann etwas nur ein
hobby bleiben solange ich damit wirklich
geld verdienen
und ich meine das war komplett falsch
es bleibt nicht für mich ein hobby wenn
ich damit geld verdienen sondern finde
ich ist ein hobby etwas was ich mache
weil es mir spaß macht und nicht weil
ich damit geld verdienen
natürlich kann hobby und beruf
einhergehen aber für mich ist es so wenn
hobby und beruf einhergeht kommt es
irgendwann immer zu der sache dass es
einem keinen spaß mehr macht nicht weil
die tätigkeit einem spaß einem kleinen
spaß gemacht sondern einfach weil man es
vielleicht zu oft macht oder soweit
stellt euch das mal vor
anhand eines beispiels ihr liebt fußball
spielen und ihr geht trefft euch mit
freunden um 10 uhr morgens in einem
sommertag und geht fußball spielen und
alles ist super aber irgendwann seid ihr
einfach da und hab einfach wirklich gar
keinen bock mehr auf fußball und dieser
moment tritt ein
es ist bei jeder aktivität oder beim
essen es ist doch auch so ihr fress
bricht die bock auffressen fress und
dann seid ihr richtig vollgefressen dann
habt ihr überhaupt keinen bock mehr
auffressen
das ist immer so und so ähnlich sehe ich
das mit youtube so man hat den mega bock
auf youtube und sagte okay ich mache
jetzt youtube aber irgendwann kommt
dieser moment wo man sagt okay jetzt
habe ich einfach wirklich keinen poken
videos zu lernen und da braucht kein
youtuber lügen ich sage dass er selber
auch ganz offenen videos zu ja ich hatte
heute einfach mal keinen bock und video
hochzuladen
es gibt einfach tage hat man einfach
bock was anderes machen aber wenn man
das komplett 24/7 als job ausübt fühlt
man sich gezwungen ein video trotzdem
hochschülern also ich würde mich dazu
gezwungen fühlen und das ist quasi so
die sache ich will dass youtube für mich
ein hobby bleibt weil hobbys bleiben für
mich nur hobbys wenn man damit kein geld
erwirtschaftet und deswegen studiere ich
nebenbei damit ich einfach nebenbei noch
einen abschluss in der tasche habe mit
dem ich mich dann irgendwie jemand
doktor machen kann und ihnen die
leichter einen job finde und das youtube
quasi mal neben dingen bleibt das ist
die einzige sache natürlich nebenbei
mein studiengang macht mir ultra viel
spaß also ich bin mega gerne der uni
und ich mache das nicht nur aus dem
grund weil ich das nicht will dass ich
irgendwann das quasi das youtube mir
keinen bock mehr macht und blabla das
thema was natascha hat es ist natürlich
so der hauptgrund zu 40 prozent aber
natürlich auch noch zu 20 es macht mir
einfach spaß zu studieren 20% man lernt
der stadt viel besser kämpfen 20
man findet neue leute zu 21 prozent sind
schon wieder 80 prozent voll viele
gründe man ist selbstständig man zieht
von zu hause weg alles mögliche ganz
ganz viele sachen vorteile einfach dass
man studiert ich meine zum beispiel
derzeit in der uni muss sich im
businessplan schreiben das ist wie man
ein unternehmen aufbauen würde das sind
35 seiten die ich wirklich eine arbeit
schreiben da wird sich jeder mensch
sagen ja das ist total beschissene
scheiß arbeit schreiben was ich mir da
einfach denke ist das da lernst du was
fürs leben da lernst du wie man
unternehmen gründet das heißt irgendwann
wenn ich jetzt dann denn ich bin im jahr
oder in einem halben jahr mit meinem
studium kann ich ein unternehmen gründen
und weiß wie das geht und weiß alle
wirtschaftlichen aspekte bwl vwl
marketing sachen alles habe ich schon
gelernt und das finde ich einfach so
cool und ich weiss ich will ist es
überhaupt nicht geblendet dieses video
ich mache jetzt mal vor ich bin bei 20
minuten sehe ich hier gerade ich könnte
stundenlang darüber reden warum ihr
nicht vornehmen sollte die youtube zu
machen ich weiß ich bin selber youtuber
aber ich hätte das einfach wenn leute
der meinung sind ja ich will youtuber
werden leute ich bin selber kein
youtuber ich mache youtube-videos klar
würde ich das auch deklarieren was
machen aber ich würde mich wirklich
hauptsächlich als student betiteln weil
ich sitze am tag acht studien der uni
ticker also vier stunden davon noch
nicht die stunden nicht dafür
und noch mal irgendwie vier stunden in
westlichen youtube-videos und den rest
freizeit und wenn man sich dann eben
möglich gut einteilt dann kriegt man das
hin ich will keinen youtuber hören von
wegen ich schaff ich nebenbei zu
studieren oder eine ausbildung natürlich
schaffte das hat da waren falschen zeit
flandern weil ich schaffe es seit zwei
jahren und mir geht's super und ja also
ihr merkt schon wollt ihr mal dass ich
darüber irgendwie livestream mache
vielleicht you know oder so
ich mag ja eigentlich nicht so gern
gegen den leuten da werde ich an mir so
ein bisschen suspekt erscheinen
aber ich würde gern mal einfach schöne
stunde darüber quatschen es ihm noch
fragen stellen könnt nicht meine
schlimmste erfahrung waren oder so aber
das erstmal so warum studiere ich weil
ich nicht will dass dauer das dass
youtube sich irgendwann mal mir von
hobby zum beruf entwickelt und dass sich
youtube machen muss auch wenn ich es
nicht will und einfach damit ich so eine
quasi rücklage habe dass ich sehe okay
ich hab was geschafft dass ich nicht
nach zwei jahren wenn ich jetzt
irgendwann kein youtube machen sollte
oder so gott bewahre ich hoffe nicht
dass ich hoffe dass mir spaß macht nicht
als niemand sagen okay ich habe jetzt
gar nichts erreicht oder so aber dass
ich wirklich ich leider viel zu viel
wenn euch das gefallen hat dass ich
wirklich einfach mal ich sehe die
tonspur die die ganze zeit durch in den
normalen videos und als pausen zwischen
den wo ich weiß nicht ich schneide und
einwendungen mache wenn euch das
gefallen hat lassmann like da ich habe
mich persönlich gequatscht ich muss
jetzt zwei stunden autofahren und was
schön darüber zu reden oder also ich
fragen leute ich weiß in dem noch in
jedem anderen video jetzt mal real talk
würde ich jetzt sagen irgendwie was zu
67 minuten geht was er darauf dass
möglichst viele leute zu erreichen und
möglichst knapp das ganze zu schneiden
knackig dass es wirklich ein ding ist
würde ich sagen raus und scheiß video
packe ich weg aber das hier ist
minecraft und bin jetzt halt bei 22
minuten aber wenn wir jetzt noch dran
sein alter hat das heißt dass sie nicht
zum ende gespielt habt oder das ist
wirklich komplett an geschenke durch
geschaut habe schreibt mir mal ein
kommentar wie davon haltet vielleicht
jetzt nicht unbedingt wenn ihr 14 15
seit überhaupt nichts gegen euch so ich
find's cool das mit euch das an struktur
quasi schon so ein bisschen lieb das
werk quasi bildung was ich gerade
gemacht habe vielleicht nicht von euch
jetzt lange kommentare über studium über
das arbeitsleben sondern eher von leuten
die gleich zu halten wie ich so 20 21 so
um den dreh wie steht ihr zu der ganzen
sache ja ich will jetzt gar keinen hut
mehr setzen hier am ende sondern einfach
nur sagen danke fürs zuschauen hat mir
echt mega spaß gemacht darüber zu reden
ja